have delivered a extremely important
judgment this morning
they have overturned the decision of the
appeal court and ruled that the
government
did act lawfully when it ruled
that the terminal the third runway
heathrow could be built so this is a
defeat
for the environmental campaigners who
back in february
were celebrating what looked like a
landmark judgment
overturning the approval effectively of
the third runway at heathrow
the supreme court have overturned the
appeal court they have endorsed the
original decision
in this legal process that began back in
2019 that the divisional court made a
correct decision in ruling
that the secretary of state for
transport at the time chris grayling
had actually acted lawfully in approving
this third runway the heart of this
decision is whether the government
was bound to take into account in its
decision on heathrow
its commitment under the paris climate
accord which
under which the uk has agreed along with
governments around the world to keep try
and keep temperatures below
less than two degrees of pre-industrial
targets that was the original target it
then moved to
1.5 degrees higher and that was the nub
of this case the appeal court ruled that
chris grayling should have used 1.5
degrees as the benchmark and on that
basis the environmental
and impact of a third runway would have
meant it was impossible for the uk to
remain within those targets
this court has now overturned that so
the third runway at heathrow
is back on now this of course has major
implications uh for the locality around
heathrow
it has big implications for the future
of infrastructure projects in the uk
that judgment back in february
seemed to change the rules and that
every big infrastructure project the
likes of hs2
new power stations would be have to take
paris into account they won't
have to now and of course the prime
minister now has a decision to make
boris johnson said he'd lie in front of
the bulldozers at heathrow
he has to consider that again